We now have a new poll about Americans view
on the proposed but still not passed covid
relief bill of Joe Biden. And Democrats will
be speaking to Democratic Congressman Roxana
a little bit later today. And I'm going to ask him
what's going on and how quickly does he think this
is going to move forward. But there is a new
Politico morning consult poll which shows that
76 percent of all Americans strongly support or
somewhat support the covid-19 relief bill. This is
the one point nine trillion dollar bill, not that
tiny six hundred billion dollar package that some
Republicans propose. This is the big boy. Only 17
percent of Americans somewhat oppose or strongly
oppose the package. The rest don't even have to
have no opinion at this point. And stunningly,
among Republicans, 60 percent of Republican
voters strongly or somewhat support the
one point nine trillion dollar covid relief
package. This is a really big deal because
in the United Way, it's a big deal for
a bunch of different reasons. No. One,
in the United States over the last eight to
10 years, the level of political division
and polarization makes it really difficult to
ever have more than 50 or 60 percent support
for almost anything. After the Sandy Hook
shooting during Barack Obama's presidency,
there was something like 80, 80 or 90 percent
support for universal background checks for
firearm transactions of all kinds. This means
eliminating. Every mechanism by which you could
obtain a firearm without a background check, 88,
90 percent support, and it still didn't pass.
And if you hadn't been paying attention to this
reality up until then, it was another reminder
that our elected officials are not actually
representing the views of their constituents,
because if they were with 80 to 90 percent support
for that, it would have passed. We now are seeing
essentially every Republican, although
I believe if it comes down to it,
some Republicans will vote for the covid-19 relief
bill proposed at one point nine trillion dollars
because some pragmatic Republicans recognize that
their constituents want it. But at this point,
you have 76 percent of the country saying
we want this passed this it's been proposed.
It's been voted on in the House. Joe Biden
wants it. Democrats want it. Presumably,
it would pass the Senate with 50 at minimum, 50
votes. And Kamala Harris is the tie breaking vote.
And yet we aren't seeing any Republicans come out
and say this is popular with the American people
and it's my responsibility to represent them. 76
percent support and even 60 percent of Republicans
supporting this and not a single Republican for
now has said, let's do this, I want to vote for
this. So, as I've said before, let them vote
it down. Democrats should be spinning this
accurately as this has bipartisan support. We're
not talking about Republican senators who are
against it. We're talking about with the people.
Seventy six percent of the country, 60 percent of
Republicans support this. There is rarely anything
as bipartisan when it comes to public support
as this, where our Republican elected officials on
it pass it via budget reconciliation or attempt to
let every single Republican who is committed
to voting against it do it, pass it via budget
reconciliation. You know, you have the votes with
fifty. Joe Manchin said he supports it. As far as
I last saw, that was about a week ago. Kamala
Harris would be the tie breaking vote, have Joe
Biden sign it. And if every Republican really
feels confident that they can vote against this
without suffering with their own constituents,
let them do it. I don't understand who it is that
Republican elected officials are representing by
opposing this. Certainly not their constituents,
are they? I mean, you know, where we typically
go is are they representing corporate interests?
Are they representing donor interests? Are
they representing lobbyists interests? I
don't exactly know. But we know that certain
staking out certain positions for Republicans
is very lucrative in terms of fundraising.
And maybe that's all that this is. I don't
know the answer. We'll talk to Roxana
about it a little bit later today,
but it's time to do it. It's
it's just time to get it passed.
If you can think of any reason why Democrats
at this point should not go forward with
the one point nine trillion dollar covid
relief bill through budget reconciliation,
requiring only a simple majority. Let me know.
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman,